[Aplausos]
[Música]
y por fin tras muchos tiras y aflojas el
break shit se hizo de una vez por todas
realidad un proyecto una misión un deseo
que parecía algo tan improbable como
descabellado hoy ya es un hecho desde
comienzos del 2021 el reino unido-
camina ya en solitario por los
truculentos caminos de la agenda
política y económica mundial la antigua
potencia dominante del mundo se enfrenta
ahora a un nuevo futuro incierto y
repleto de dificultades por ejemplo para
que os hagáis una idea la comisión
europea ha estimado que el break 7
supondrá a la economía británica más de
40 mil millones de libras por año unos
56 mil millones de dólares por su parte
la oficina de responsabilidad
presupuestaria del reino unido- del
propio reino unido- apunta a una caída
en la productividad de casi el 4% y a
niveles de inflación más altos los
motivos que explican todas estas
previsiones tienen que ver con la salida
del reino unido- del proyecto europeo de
integración económica comercial y
política fijaos
[Música]
aunque el acuerdo comercial alcanzado
entre el reino unido y la unión europea
a finales del 2020 suprimió la
posibilidad de establecer aranceles
comerciales no frenó los procedimientos
aduaneros que dificultan el comercio es
decir los empresarios británicos se
enfrentan ahora a un montón de papeles
inspecciones y burocracia de todo tipo
esos flujos comerciales hacia el viejo
continente hablamos de cosas como los
controles de salud los controles de
seguridad o la liquidación de impuestos
en aduanas
[Música]
y ojo porque no es un asunto menor cada
año el reino unido- exporta a la unión
europea en bienes y servicios unos
400.000 millones de dólares en esta
línea una encuesta de la make you key
encontró que casi tres cuartas partes de
las empresas han experimentado retrasos
en el traslado de mercancías con la
unión europea durante los últimos meses
incluso la lucrativa industria
financiera de la city de londres ha
sufrido un buen golpe y de hecho como
anécdota podemos decir que ámsterdam ha
desplazado ya a londres como el mercado
principal de acciones de empresas
europeas
amsterdam supera a londres como el
principal centro de negociación de
acciones de europa
la salida del reino unido de la unión
europea provoca un cambio en la
negociación de acciones y derivados
ahora bien un momento quiere decir todo
esto que el 'break' si te es una idea
estructuralmente mala que está condenada
a empobrecer irremediablemente a los
británicos en qué posición se encuentra
exactamente al reino unido- que el
planteamiento tienen hoy por hoy en
downing street para enfrentarse a esta
situación y quizás la
más importante que todas estamos a las
puertas del renacer de la grandeza
británica o al borde de su declive final
atentos
y seguro que todos los caminos parecen
malos
[Aplausos]
queridos amigos amigas de visual
política en esta ocasión no os voy a
hablar del próximamente éxito que el
reino unido ha tenido respecto alan
europea a la hora de gestionar la
vacunación contra la cob y 19no lo que
nos interesa en este vídeo es mirar
hacia adelante y la primera pregunta que
tenemos que responder y tener clara es
exactamente qué papel juega el reino
unido- en la economía mundial vale lo sé
estoy seguro de que todos conocéis el
peso que tiene la city de londres y la
industria financiera británica hablamos
de una de las dos grandes capitales de
las finanzas mundiales para que os
hagáis una idea tan sólo los servicios
financieros contribuyen con casi 200.000
millones de dólares al pib del reino
unido más del 11 por ciento de todas las
empresas cotizadas del mundo cotizan en
la bolsa de londres pero un momento
porque esa no es ni mucho menos su única
fortaleza aunque te pueda parecer
sorprendente y suele pasar desapercibido
el reino unido sigue siendo una de las
grandes economías mundiales hablamos de
la quinta mayor economía del mundo tan
sólo por detrás de estado
china japón y alemania y también del
quinto mayor exportador de bienes y
servicios
[Música]
y no sólo eso el peso de la inversión
extranjera directa esto es lo que se
invierte por ejemplo en fábricas y
muebles y empresas en la economía
británica es mucho mayor que en casos
como el de alemania o francia
por otro lado reino unido- ocupa la
cuarta posición en el ranking de
innovación global es el tercer mayor
destino mundial para la inversión en
tecnología y también es el tercer país
del mundo con mayor número de unicornios
[Música]
si lo habéis escuchado bien se suele
pasar por alto pero el reino unido- no
solo es una potencia financiera también
es una potencia tecnológica sobre todo
si lo comparamos con el resto de europa
los británicos construyen más satélites
y atraen más inversión digital que
cualquier otro país europeo
[Música]
y no se trata sólo del peso económico
desde el punto de vista de la seguridad
el reino unido tiene el segundo mayor
presupuesto militar de la otan y el
mayor de toda europa tiene la mayor
capacidad para operar a nivel mundial
del 'viejo continente' y sus agencias de
inteligencia ocupan los primeros puestos
mundiales y luego está el conocido como
poder blando este país es el segundo
destino favorito para los estudiantes
extranjeros tras eeuu derecho uno de
cada cuatro países de todo el mundo
tiene un jefe de estado o de gobierno
que estudió en el reino unido
uno de cada cuatro es amigo se llama
simple y llanamente influencia y todo
eso por no hablar del alcance global de
la premier a la bbc los colegios
británicos o la música
[Música]
es decir en otras palabras lo miremos
por donde lo miremos el reino unido
sigue siendo uno de los países más
importantes e influyentes de todo el
planeta y lo que es aún más los
británicos quieren seguir teniendo
protagonismo en la agenda internacional
pero ahora bien es evidente que su
situación ha cambiado estar fuera de la
unión europea supone tener que volver a
construir una política exterior una
política comercial e incluso una
política de seguridad propia después de
haber dejado la unión europea el reino
unido ha comenzado un nuevo capítulo en
nuestra historia estamos abiertos al
mundo
boris johnson queridos amigos amigas
esto que vamos a ver a continuación es
el planteamiento la estrategia la
política con la que el gobierno
británico quiere maximizar y consolidar
su papel a nivel mundial esta es la
receta la fórmula con la que quieren
superar el break it y europa atentos
[Música]
la conquista de oriente
además del acuerdo de comercio y
cooperación firmado con la unión europea
para evitar los temidos aranceles entre
comienzos del 2019 y el 2021 el gobierno
británico ha firmado ya acuerdos
comerciales con 66 países fuera de la
unión europea
el objetivo que se han fijado en londres
es que para finales del 2020 el país
tenga acuerdos comerciales en vigor con
países que representan al menos el 80%
del comercio británico en cualquier caso
de momento han establecido un nuevo
sistema global de aranceles para
aquellas importaciones que no estén
cubiertas por un acuerdo comercial que
es más sencillo y más bajo que el de la
unión europea
en total desde el 1 de enero de 2021
casi el 60 por ciento de todo el
comercio entrará al país libre de
aranceles en lo que respecta al 40%
restante los tipos se sitúan te media
por debajo de la convención
internacional no asuma al comienzo no
obstante era una apuesta británica hoy
por hoy pasa por tres campos de juego
principales eeuu el área cáncer y sobre
todo la reconquista de oriente si os
parece empecemos por el principio
eeuu es el mayor socio comercial y el
mayor inversor del país por eso una de
las prioridades absolutas que londres ha
fijado es lograr un tratado de libre
comercio con la gran potencia
norteamericana eso podría reforzar el
papel del reino unido- como el punto de
conexión natural entre eeuu y la unión
europea al tiempo que mejoraría el
acceso de las empresas británicas a un
mercado de cientos y cientos de miles de
millones de dólares
[Música]
y esto amigos esto es algo que parece
mucho más fácil de lograr que un acuerdo
de libre comercio entre eeuu y la unión
europea es decir que aquí el break sheet
podría suponer un claro viento a favor
luego por otra parte y tal y como ya os
contamos en un pasado vídeo en londres
ha cobrado mucha fuerza la idea de
reforzar la unión con la integración
económica del país con canadá australia
y nueva zelanda con estos tres países la
relación a todos los niveles es muy
buena y aunque parezca un pequeño club
juntos suponen el 7 por ciento de la
economía mundial pero sobre todo el
punto quizás más disruptivo de la nueva
política económica y comercial de
londres es su apuesta definida por
reconquistar oriente
[Música]
en down en street lo tienen claro el
lindo pacífico es el motor de
crecimiento global la mitad de la
población el 40% del pib global y las
mayores tasas de crecimiento económico
se sitúan en lo que históricamente se
consideró oriente hablamos de países
como japón china la india indonesia
vietnam o corea del sur
[Música]
fijaos el comercio entre el reino unido
y le enviase más que duplicó entre el
2007 y 2019 ya comienzos del 2021 los
dos países han firmado una asociación
comercial mejorada un acuerdo con el que
esperan volver a duplicar el comercio
mutuo para el 2030 y que además abre la
puerta a un futuro tratado de libre
comercio por cierto hemos hablado ya de
ello en el boletín que cada semana
enviamos a todos nuestros patrones y
tenemos apoyarnos os dejamos el enlace
en la descripción el caso es que londres
considera el mercado indio como
absolutamente clave los dos países
mantienen estrechos lazos históricos
sociales y económicos y si la economía
india despega de una vez por todas eso
podría ser un enorme viento de cola para
la economía británica pero amigos
la jugada quizás más atrevida
sorprendente ha sido la solicitud para
integrarse en el cpd pp el acuerdo
heredero del pp el acuerdo transpacífico
que donald trump mandó a hacer puñetas
nada más llegar a la casa blanca por
cierto una clara derrota para los
yanquis ya que el resto de países
siguieron adelante sin la potencia
norteamericana creando un mercado de 500
millones de personas y en torno al 14
por ciento del pib mundial
hablamos de japón australia vietnam
singapur canadá méjico malasia brunei
nueva zelanda y perú un acuerdo al que
próximamente parece que podrían unirse
con la del sur o tailandia además del
reino unido pero vamos a ver por qué
demonios el reino unido quiere
integrarse en un acuerdo comercial
transpacífico qué ventaja puede tener
vincularse a países tan distantes pues
bien fijaos
[Música]
más allá del acceso a 500 millones de
consumidores integrarse en este acuerdo
metería de lleno al reino unido en el
marco diplomático y sobre todo muy
importante en el marco regulatorio por
ejemplo en lo que concierne a los
servicios y el entorno digital dos de
los puntos fuertes de la economía
británica es decir para entendernos
integrarse en este tipo de acuerdos le
permitirá al reino unido- adaptarse más
fácilmente y también contribuir al
desarrollo del marco regulatorio de
algunos de los mercados con mayor
potencial económico de todo el mundo
y así de esta forma mirando directamente
a eeuu alcance y sobre todo a oriente es
como el gobierno británico de boris
johnson quiere convertir al reino unido
en el operador europeo de referencia en
el comercio mundial
esta es la gran apuesta con la que
trabaja el gobierno británico y con la
que esperan rentabilizar el break city
además dan por hecho que poco a poco la
mayoría de las dificultades que han
surgido en el comercio con la unión
europea irán limando se o desapareciendo
y que por tanto los costes de la salida
se reducirán progresivamente pero amigos
el proyecto de johnson no se
circunscribe exclusivamente al campo
comercial si hablamos de aspirar a
mantener un rol de potencia en el mundo
entonces tenemos que inevitablemente
hablar también de que ocurre con el
campo militar y eso es algo que en
londres no han olvidado atentos
el regreso de la royal navy hubo un día
en el que la royal navy fue dueña y
señora de los males del mundo la punta
de lanza el elemento indispensable gran
referencia del mayor imperio que jamás
el mundo haya conocido sin embargo eso
es algo que queda para los libros de
historia lo cierto es que las últimas
dos décadas no han sido precisamente
buenas para las fuerzas armadas
británicas y especialmente para la royal
navy la pérdida de buena parte de sus
capacidades anfibias de la aviación
embarcada y de un buen número de barcos
supusieron un declive sin precedentes
por ejemplo si en 1991 la marina
británica contaba con 34 fragatas y 17
más en diferentes fases de producción en
2020 apenas contaba con 13
la situación era tal que en 2010 el
gobierno retiró de servicio los harriers
de la marina quedándose por tanto sin a
la embarcada y en 2018 ante la falta de
presupuesto vendieron a brasil el h ms o
sean uno de esos buques para despliegues
anfibios más importantes sin embargo
ahora la situación puede ser
completamente diferente la llegada de
los nuevos portaaviones clase queen
elisabeth los nuevos cazas embarcados
f-35 la construcción de nuevas fragatas
los nuevos submarinos de ataque astuto y
los nuevos planes de submarinos
estratégicos el proyecto es axesor el
programa militar más caro de la historia
del reino unido- todo parece mostrar el
regreso de buenos tiempos para la royal
navy pero amigos amigas sobre todo lo
que ha cambiado que es la voluntad
política proteger a nuestro pueblo
nuestra patria y nuestra democracia es
el primer deber de cualquier gobierno
por lo que he comenzado el mayor
programa de inversión en defensa desde
el final de la guerra fría esto de
mostrar a nuestros aliados en europa y
más allá que siempre pueden contar con
el reino unido cuando realmente importa
boris johnson
no británico ha anunciado un incremento
sustancial del gasto militar y un nuevo
plan adicional de inversión y
modernización de las fuerzas armadas de
más de 34.000 millones de dólares por
los próximos cuatro años plan al que hay
que sumar los que ya estaban en marcha
en total hablamos de una cifra que puede
superar los 50 mil millones en cuatro o
cinco años supone con mucha diferencia
la mayor inversión en las fuerzas
armadas desde el final de la guerra fría
además de esta gran cifra una buena
parte irá a parar a programas de alta
tecnología y también a la creación de
una nueva fuerza cibernética y un nuevo
comando espacial e incluso el gobierno
británico ha decidio romper con su
política nuclear si en 2010 anunciaron
una fuerte reducción de su arsenal de
armas nucleares ahora han tomado la
decisión contraria el reino unido
incrementará su arsenal de armas
nucleares hasta las 260 y vas 80 más que
el objetivo anterior pero eso no es todo
para impulsar su presencia internacional
el gobierno británico no solo apuesta
por mantener desplegado uno de sus
nuevos portaaviones en indochina o
incrementar el número de tropas
estacionadas en el extranjero por
ejemplo para mejorar su operatividad con
las de países aliados como australia
sino que también está estudiando la
apertura de nuevas bases militares en el
extranjero se especula con la
posibilidad de establecer nuevas bases
militares permanentes en singapur o
brunei lo que se sumarían a las
instalaciones que ya tienen en bahrein
diego garcía o belice
el aire amigos es que el reino unido no
solo sigue siendo un aliado prioritario
de los eeuu sino también un país
decisivo gracias a sus capacidades de
despliegue y disuasión es decir que el
reino unido vuelva a ser toda una
potencia reconocida a nivel mundial una
referencia comercial financiera y
también militar por así decirlo esta es
la otra cara del break sheet de la que
nunca se habla claro que está por ver si
londres logra salirse con la suya y
desde luego también hay muchos retos por
delante no resulta tan fácil hablaremos
de ello en el futuro pero de momento
turno para ti qué futuro crees que le
espera el reino unido- crees que los
planes de boris johnson llegarán a un
buen término volveremos a ver a la royal
navy controlando los mares del mundo
déjanos tu respuesta abajo en los
comentarios y si este vídeo te resultado
interesante no olvides darle a like y
suscribirte a visual política un saludo
y hasta la próxima
[Música]